now that the latest climate conference
is underway in glasgow scotland and
greta tunberg has once again shown the
world that she is the conscience of her
generation someone must tell her
you may be the conscience of your
generation but you don't represent it
i really wish you did greta but you
don't
but i can show you who does
greta you have 13 million followers on
instagram which is great but kylie
jenner has 279 million which is more
i mean seriously who is the real
influencer in that generation the model
citizen or the model
the young woman who refuses to fly are
the one who refuses to fly commercial
you see what i'm saying greta gets where
she's going on a sailboat powered by the
wind kylie takes a private jet powered
by exxon
and she's 21 times more popular
now this is not a screed against comfort
or capitalism i'm fond of both
and i give kylie credit she's built a
massive business empire without ever
releasing a sex tape
[Applause]
and like her dad she's a self-made woman
[Applause]
but kylie embodies and embraces a
lifestyle that is pretty much the
opposite of carbon neutral and the
younger generations [ __ ] love it
last week kylie posted a tour of her
shoe closet which houses well over a
thousand pairs she also has entire rooms
of things she only sworn once
i don't think greta would approve of
that
in polls young people always claim to be
more concerned about climate change than
other generations but they don't act
like it
they throw around buzz words like
sustainable and shame people who forget
to bring a cloth bag to trader joe's but
one of their favorite youtubers is mr
beast who's famous for stunts like i
gave my 40 millionth subscriber 40 cars
jason derulo celebrated his 22nd
millionth follower by eating 22
hamburgers
the cognitive dissonance between
planet-destroying conspicuous
consumption and planet-saving rhetoric
is breathtaking
you say you love greta and her message
but everything else you love is a
climate disaster
far from rejecting consumerism young
people are so obsessed with labels that
venerable fashion houses like valenciaga
have pivoted from selling couture
dresses to rich women to selling
baseball hats to teenagers
and where does it 20 something get the
money to pay 400
for a hat that borrows the bernie
sanders logo because
[Applause]
because you're like a socialist and
stuff
from mommy and daddy of course those
huge [ __ ] who ruined the planet
oh and also maybe by trading bitcoin the
mining of which is worse for the
environment than actual mining
cryptocurrency uses more energy than
netflix apple facebook microsoft and
google combined and more than some
entire nations and yet young people
could not love it more if it came with a
side of avocado toast
94
of crypto buyers are either millennials
or gen z which makes it ring a little
hollow when you're out there chanting
for us to put the planet ahead of
prophets
and what do crypto fans say about this
they say
well yes it uses too much energy now but
in the future
oh yeah the future that's right same
thing my generation said let them handle
it in the future i'll get mine now
like bitcoin the smartphone is a huge
contributor to carbon emissions because
the cloud isn't an actual cloud of
course it's a vast network of servers
using energy and all that liking and
following and subscribing requires lots
of fossil fuels and yet you would need
the jaws of life to pry a phone out of
the hands of anyone under 30.
[Applause]
what would it take to convince gen z and
millennials to give up their phones a
pollster once asked
43 said it would take five million
dollars
to give up their phone one in ten said
they'd sacrifice a finger for it
that deserves a high four
look
i know it would be fire
to be able to both live like kylie and
also save the planet but you can't do
both
last year when australia was devastated
by wildfires greta reminded us that we
still fail to make the connection
between the climate crisis and
increased extreme weather events kylie 2
was moved by the disaster and tweeted
about how the loss of animal life breaks
her heart then she quickly follow up
with a post of her new 1500 louis
vuitton mink slippers
it's always so sad when fire kills
potential slippers
[Applause]
kids you're going to have to make a
choice here do you want to be
progressive or excessive
team drastic or team plastic
when kylie's lifestyle becomes uncool
and unpopular and you stop loving
bitcoin and stop thinking that stuffing
your face is harmless i'll take you
seriously until then shut the [ __ ] up
about how older generations ruined the
planet
we we get it
boomers dropped the ball on the
environment we did we dropped it like it
was hot
and for that i can only say
whoops
yeah you're right we dropped it but have
you picked it up
i wish your generation was better than
mine i really do but the sad truth is
we're completely the same
lots of talk and at the end of the day
hopelessly seduced and addicted to
pigging out on convenience
luxury and consumption
so that's it
you can either be the fake tits and
private jet generation or the one that
saves the planet but you can't be both
because fake tits are not biodegradable
you